my name is Sophie temple and I came to
New Zealand 54 years ago this coming
January I knew where New Zealand was and
I knew they had sheep not a lot else we
looked at the states we look at Canada
we looked at Australia we looked at New
Zealand and of all these countries we
found New Zealand to be you know the
best place for us to go it's a very
stable and peaceful country and we were
at a stage of our lives that we we
wanted to make a move you know in an
area where that stability you know for
bringing up a family that was there was
something interesting
I'm joking I applied for the job and
then I got the job I was like 7 yeah and
she's like oh wow it's real yeah we jump
ship never been here before
knew nothing about it completely place
well we arrived in Christchurch on the
day of the earthquake so it was even
more than what we expected and the way
that we chose to see this was that New
Zealand had given us a gift because we
were immediately part of the story
[Music]